sorti mercredi sur les écrans du dernier
film de francis veber il est intitulé
les fugitifs
on y retrouve le couple vedette gérard
depardieu et pierre richard gérard
depardieu est quitte avec moi ce soir
sur ce plateau bonsoir gérard alors ce
film un peu étrange mais j'ai vu hier
ses films un peu étrange qui hésite
constamment entre entre la farce on rit
beaucoup mais aussi entre le pathétique
le drame histoire un peu dure histoire
d'un chômeur qui fait un hold up et qui
vous retrouve ou qui est un truand est
définitive et c'est une histoire un peu
folle oui je pense exactement
non mais fait divers d'aujourd'hui c'est
magnifique d'avoir à faire une comédie
sur le chômage
alors c'est sûr le chômage mais c'est un
peu plus compliqué on va voir un extrait
tout de suite je rappelle l'histoire
vous êtes un truand qui veut se venger
des bicyclettes vous sortez de prison et
vous allez poser un chèque dans une
banque et là vous êtes pris en otage par
un parent à chômeurs au bout du rouleau
qui est son dernier ressort il y vient
de faire un hold up
il vous prend en otage on va voir ça et
s'explique la suite du film de suite est
extraite pour mieux comprendre de quoi
on va parler maintenant
et voilà j'espère les pages et voilà la
prise d'otage maintenant chez duca c'est
du canon mais ici
et oui oh [ __ ]
connard moi je dis conner
makouri joue là ces malades du rein et
écouter ce que tu veux je reviens moi je
suis l'otage
qu'est ce qui dit qu'il est l'otage sous
de ma gueule ou quoi l'attachement des
sept otages de gros 10 décembre
je me sens pas très bien à grenade alors
parlant d'elle mais conventuels voilà on
comprend bien avec le thème du film donc
vous saviez vous imaginez que reste
cette espèce de double lecture quand
vous avez accepté scénario avec francis
veber on est toujours un double lecture
et puis avec pierre pierre richard aussi
on a fait quand même trois films
ensemble l'achève où j'étais vraiment un
enfant
les compères où on a essayé d'être
adulte un peu ensemble mais franchement
drôle la limite de la farce auriez
beaucoup y avait pas ce côté un petit
peu tragique tirer vers le tragique et
voilà je dois dire que c'est magnifique
parce que justement fall est vrai pour
moi les vrais que mehdi sont celles qui
tournent vers le tragique la chaplin par
exemple qu'il a fait les lumières de la
ville c'était ses magnifiques pas
pourquoi parce qu'on a affaire à une
quotidienneté comme ça qui nous qui nous
emporte une belle émotion et là dans ce
film il ya une petite fille qui fait la
différence pour vous pour le truand que
vous êtes dans le film qui s'appelle
jeanne et qu'effectivement fait tout
basculer
oui absolument ça c'est la magie de
francis la magie de francis et aussi le
regard de pierre jeu pierre et le père
de cette petite fille puis donc moi je
suis complètement un étranger devant ça
vous aviez à 300 le scénario dans ses
magasins
mais c'est bien maintenant non on se
connaît tellement bien que gilles vaut
mieux pour ensuite travailler seul et il
est il est tellement plus fort les
d'abord c'est un tag grand tout
francis veber on a toujours peur de dire
que les hôtes à deux comédies sont sont
des auteurs on a toujours peur de notre
rire à nous c'est dommage j'aime
tellement rire et vous avez c'est
marrant nous pendent défendre - gérard
depardieu on va parler comme de vrais
moments encore parce que bon c'est votre
année il ya quatre films presque 5 dans
les 15 mois vous a fait à nouveau je
crois en ce moment c'était une grande
année pour vous et vous vend des biens
aux états unis
j'ai vu de mes yeux times vous êtes
classé parmi les trois meilleurs acteurs
du monde
ça vous surprend ça ça fait du bien en
tout cas on entend ça réchauffe
terriblement j'aimerais c'est vrai enfin
en france on a un potentiel inouï
on a fait vous avez que j'étais aux
états unis elle pas longtemps festival
new york par exemple il ya eu six films
français
c'est absolument ahurissant dans deux
voire six films français comme ça qu'ils
qui sont dispatchés dans l'est aux états
unis et ça vous donne envie d'aller
travailler aux états unis vous n'avez
jamais fait non non je pense pas je
pense que mon ami mot maître francis
debeyre valff à terme va y aller mais
c'est compliqué et ça sans vous parlait
pas l'anglais à bayonne on n'a pas du
tout le monde mais c'est moi je suis
très flatté très très flatté de
l'amérique ça bel hommage effectivement
gérard merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir je rappelle me de
films sortent donc mercredi qui
s'appelle le fugitif est un film
véritablement très étrange très
intéressant